live from Minneapolis Minnesota its
GameSpot sports presented by game tech
which has nothing to do with this game
with your hosts Nick margarita and
Michael hi um whoa gentlemen it is Super
Bowl Sunday I'm your host Nick
marguerite alongside with my buddy here
michael hi i'm michael how you doing on
this Super Bowl Sunday
man I am hyped up for this matchup I am
as well we got a tough matchup between
the New England Patriots in the
Philadelphia Eagles L rematch of the
2005 Super Bowl Michael tell us a little
bit more about this this this matchup we
got here well it's a matchup between the
old guard and the new guard Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady are in their
eighth Super Bowl together and last time
that we saw the Eagles in the Super Bowl
was against the Patriots the Eagles team
is completely new from that last Super
Bowl appearance we got Nick Foles taken
over for Carson Wentz we're to see how
he handles the pressure but also Doug
Peterson in his second year as the
Eagles head coach this team is off to a
very good start
Doug Peterson dougie and right into the
Super Bowl let's get down to the field
to get into that action and here come
the Eagles led by Nick Foles Tulsa
Loompa Bella our buddy Nick pulls what a
lack of experience am i right well he's
been with the Eagles before he knows
what he's supposed to be doing as the
backup but he or thrusted back into the
starting role for the Eagles taking over
Carson Wentz this is a the biggest game
of his career the biggest stage and here
comes somebody who's accustomed to that
stage Tom Brady you got to give it to
him you got to respect his game he's
done this for so many years and it's no
surprise to see the Pats back in Super
Bowl led by Tom Brady no surprise just
like his diet Tom Brady is back
defending his Super Bowl champion all
right let's take a quick break and go
down to the field to our sideline
reporter Robert Hanley Rob what's the
atmosphere in US Bank Stadium like right
now thanks Nick yeah the atmosphere
behind me is super cold below freezing
to be exact but I'll tell you what's not
freezing is the body heat from these
players super hot back to you thank you
for that report Rob it sounds like US
Bank Stadium is hyped up for the Super
Bowl
but now we're gonna get down to the coin
toss and here's the toss it looks as if
the Eagles and Nick Foles have won the
coin toss you would assume they would
elect to receive here right Michael
oh no we'll see I mean you do want to
get the ball in the second half as well
so I don't know you also want to choose
what wind direction they're holding but
this is indoor stadium so that's not
gonna be a factor actually so I'm uh I'm
making [ __ ] up I believe the Eagles have
elected to receive so they're gonna get
that high-powered offense in motion
right away Super Bowl 50 - here it comes
coming out of the end zone oh yes slam
down at the 24 yard line
they got decent field position to start
but he probably should have kneeled the
ball instead alright well here comes
Nick Foles coming out there to command
that Eagles offense he's trying to fill
in some pretty big shoes with Carson
Wentz beat it here comes the play Nick
Foles
it's a handoff not to think he's thrown
the ball downfield
what a catch got 42 yards from Nelson
aglow he's a young receiver who's really
busted onto the scene and really came up
big for the Eagles this season alright
the Eagles are now in the red zone let's
see what they can do oh no partner a
tough series there for the Eagles
offense looks like they're gonna have to
kick the field goal yeah at least
they're gonna get some points on the
board you know he can't get that
touchdown but you have to come away with
something young kicker Jake Elliott
let's see if he can get this through the
uprights he's got it it's good he splits
the uprights the Eagles are on the board
three nothing Philadelphia here in Super
Bowl 50 to Tom Brady entering the huddle
you got to respect him he has five Super
Bowl rings he's got his eyes set on a
6-1 this could really cement him in the
history of the NFL as a greatest
quarterback of all time but he has a
whole game ahead of them well this is
the first play of the offensive series
for the Patriots let's see if they can
get that ball rolling all right here
comes single back set for the Patriots
the head office at the
what they're not gonna kill him he oh
wait touchdown New England Patriots and
that's a strong showing from the
Patriots early on Dion Lewis showing his
old team why they should have kept him
around but the 73-yard touchdown and the
Patriots offense is into a flaming start
here at Super Bowl 52 it is now 7 to 3
New England all right here comes Nick
Foles dropping back to pass in the
shotgun Nelson a glory we've got a big
play in their first drive dropping the
ball here you've got to keep your hands
on the ball you got to secure that you
gotta hold on to the ball a galore I
can't believe he allowed that ball to
come out so easy and here comes Tom
Brady and the Patriots offense off that
hot first play all right here comes Tom
Brady it's a fake handoff he's dropping
back to the pass he throws
what a catch Oh No Brandon cooks dropped
the ball
second fumble the game and we're only in
the first quarter these receivers need
to keep their hands on the ball it's not
just about catching but they need to
secure it as they run after the catch
that is the truth and here comes Nick
Foles and the Eagles offense back onto
the field we see Al Shean Jeffery here
he can really change the game alright
here comes Nick Foles single back set
he's gonna snap it oh he's passing he
drops back here go Nick Falls going deep
oh my goodness who was that Torrey Smith
my goodness Torrey Smith with a 40 yard
touchdown and he is dancing down in the
end zone Torrey Smith is no stranger to
the Super Bowl back when the Ravens made
it in the 2012-2013 season he was on
that roster big play for the Eagles here
and they are back on top 10 to 7
Philadelphia all right tough 13 out
series there for the Patriots Eagles in
the end zone here we go hard count from
Foles here comes the snap he drops back
oh my good oh oh is he gonna get sacked
no partner nobody touched him oh my gosh
Alshon Jeffery with the catch that was
one of the most clutch plays I've seen
ever my goodness
clutch plays complete lack of defense on
the New England Patriots we thought
Falls God got sacked on that play but he
actually just tripped on his own
teammate got back up and threw the
touchdown pass impressive stuff can you
believe it from a sack lunch to a
chicken dinner Patriots are trying to
put some points on the board just before
the first half concludes Stephen
Gostkowski with a 56 yard field goal and
he splits the uprights what a cannon
Stephen Gostkowski as look
that leg the Patriots really needed that
score because they're down a whole
possession now but they can catch up
we saw what they did last year in the
Super Bowl so this is nothing today
that's right only a seven-point
differential here Bill Belichick and
Matt Patricia I got a love that all
right ladies and gentlemen that is the
conclusion the first half of Super Bowl
50 to the Philadelphia Eagles leads 17th
to 10 let's now go down to the field and
check in with our sideline reporter
Robert handler e how's it going down
there sir thanks Nick yeah it is a
privilege to be here we are currently
waiting for JT to get on stage and do
his thing but they have recently Oh yep
bagels they just started serving bagels
on the field back to you well thank you
for that update Rob very interesting
all right so Michael looking at to the
second half what do the New England
Patriots need to do here I think on
offense they just need to keep hitting
their receivers you know grok needs to
get going I think Brandon cooks
despite the fumble you still need to
feed him the ball and Dion Lewis he
showed up with a long 78 yard run I
think he needs to get fed to the ball a
little bit more here in the second half
but we'll see what they can do feed that
man the ball alright we are just seconds
away from the second half here it's
Super Bowl 52 let's get back down to the
frozen tundra in Minnesota
all right the Eagles back in the end
zone after a quick three an app for the
Patriots Nick folds back in the shotgun
here it goes he's back he's back he's
got time all dead oh my goodness Nelson
a galore again it's another touchdown
for the Eagles they are really pulling
ahead here in Super Bowl 50 - but you
can never count the Patriots out despite
what the scoreboard says this scoreboard
is looking good if you're an Eagles fan
let's take a look at that pylon yeah
Stephen Gostkowski is getting ready for
his third field goal of the game the
Patriots seem to have trouble getting in
the end zone but they still need to put
a point
we have a little chip shot here let's
see if he can get it
and he splits the uprights from the
one-yard line
that is three for three from Gus Kowski
all right Michael the Eagles get up
field goal of their own the Patriots
with only five minutes left to go
they're gonna really need to get that
offense rolling again time is running
out we can never count him out like I
said earlier all right here comes Tom
Brady he drops back oh my goodness I
shoot that Tim Jernigan with the second
sack of the game this one could probably
seal it for them oh my goodness only
four minutes and thirty seconds left in
this one and Doug Peterson loves it this
is the Patriots last chance to really
get something going they're down two
possessions what can they do here comes
the snap Tommy back in the shotgun again
he trusts Becky pastor Chris okay oh my
goodness they can't connect he wasn't
even looking for the ball and that was
probably their last hope oh my goodness
Chris poking that looked cross loving
man he can't connect with Tom Brady on
the most important offensive play of the
game here the Eagles really sealing it
they don't even need a field goal but
they kick one anyway
32:13 17 seconds left
and the Super Bowl looks like we have a
winner and it looks like the Eagles have
sealed their fate as Super Bowl 52
champions
that's right Michael the Lombardi Trophy
is coming home to the City of Brotherly
Love Philadelphia is Super Bowl 52
champions
Doug Peterson in the Philadelphia Eagles
had a hell of a season it could have
ended any more perfectly even with
Carson Wentz's season-ending injury nick
foles is going home as the hometown hero
let's go down to the field our own
Robert Henry is there in the aftermath
[Music]
thanks Rob it looks wild down there I
hope you're having fun but
congratulations to the Philadelphia
Eagles and the city of Philadelphia this
has been a long time coming for them
congratulations on the Super Bowl win
longtime cont long time season and
that's all we have for you this year I
want to thank each and every one of you
for tuning into GameSpot Sports Network
and we'll see you next year at Superbowl
53
[Music]